uh hello everybody uh
just wanted to show you guys a quick
drive you guys know that uh
i don't know no one put any driving
videos up yet so i thought i'd do a
quick one
uh the comma 3 is very real
my phone also is real low on battery
so if we randomly cut out uh it's
probably because my phone died
um you can see the screen is very
similar
to the comma 2 except more
beautiful let's get on the highway
get over to the middle lane and then
once we're on the highway
we can chill
now we just engage it here let's go all
right
lane change uh we're on the lane full
model of course it has the exact same
laneless toggle as the comma two
uh so yeah we're just gonna chill bros
see if i try to lane change with someone
in my blind spot we get car detected in
blind spot but now that they're gone
just move over here just like the combat
two
but better and even more chill and more
beautiful
you guys can see the beautiful screen uh
on my on my windshield that oled gives a
crispiness
that you just can't compete with
anywhere it's my
uh my legs and the wheel what we do in
there
see everything uh so yeah my phone is
almost out of battery
so hopefully it's charging fast enough
it is plugged into my hyundai sonata
which we're chilling in right now
as beautiful it is beautiful guys like
i'm looking at the phone screen
and the picture looks way better on the
device you just can't capture the
crispiness of the screen
with the uncrispy iphone camera we've
got some hdr camera up in here
um
yeah uh
it's me boys got my three comma hat on
chillin here's one hand the other hand's
holding the phone
looking at the road at all times of
course it has the same driver monitoring
as the uh oh show nav
of course yeah we could just bring up a
map if we go like this
so we'll give that map a minute to load
here and there's our map you can see me
driving down
the san diego freeway uh we've opted to
remove the traffic i guess it's just not
in this rev
uh because the traffic is spotty and
kind of shitty uh
but yeah oh yeah how did i how did i
forget to show you guys that
now if we actually want to navigate to
somewhere
we can go in here we can go to
navigation that's the uh
it's telling us to make a u-turn if we
want to navigate back to the office
uh the map is online
oh i'm gonna cut in here
uh we're of course on honda's stock uh
acc not open pilots it was open pods you
could have let it go
but i'm sorry not hondas i mean
hyundai's
uh so we're just gonna get off here at
seaworld drive
let's do an automatic lane change here
boom
still got a bit of improvements to do to
the software
uh but overall you're out of the box
experience
should be greater than or equal to a
comma two
uh and that's just from a driving
perspective
from a beauty perspective it's 100
better so i could do something we could
do some of this road too
uh will the nav talk one day no it's
terrible
i never make the nap talk i wouldn't do
that to all y'all
all right so it looks like i got eight
minutes to get home
uh we can pull over here and do some
questions quickly
just find a good spot to pull over
but yeah comma three driving footage i'm
not a professional
photographer
is the lane change automatic or does it
still need the drive or nudge
still needs the driver node you don't
want automatic lane change it's not a
good feature uh
is the screen ever gonna get bigger it
does not come with a growing screen i'm
sorry
the screen on this is slightly bigger
than the screen on the comma two it's
also borderless which is really nice
um so
yeah let's uh
let's pull into this sketchy parking lot
right up next to this uh bus
yeah any quick questions
i think that was just a quick stream
real footage of the commentary driving
get yours today
at common.ai slash shop or just go to
common.ai is the screen ever going to
get smaller
uh how will it perform in the mountains
bit better than the two uh the alignment
is still centered absolutely yeah
so you'll see you'll see we can we can
toggle between
uh well actually we'll go off right here
uh so we can toggle between navigation
and uh the sidebar
if we go off off-road see we're
subscribed to comma prime
you can see in the settings here
navigation
uh you can also control this in
uh running open pilot 0.7
it's running agnos 1.1 which will be the
shipping version
got the same great toggles i think i'll
uh turn laneless on for my drive home
we have this new toggle show eta in 24
hour format
uh we can wi-fi
uh things about the device i can reset
my calibration here if i want
the dongle id the serial number we do
have an english only multi lang coming
soon
um we should really work on that will it
work anywhere
sure why not cool
thanks for watching quick drive on the
comment three i'm going home
it's nap time
you